well it is happening again classified
items have been found at a Donald Trump
storage unit in Florida it is the guy
who said no one respects classified
information as much as he does he may
have been a little bit careless with the
classified documents Rolling Stone
reports classified documents found at
Trump's storage unit with swords and
wrestling belts lawyers for the former
president turned over more sensitive
documents to the FBI after conducting an
independent search of his properties
identified additional documents with
classification markings in a search that
spanned three Trump properties including
Bedminster golf truck Club in Jersey
Trump Tower in New York and presumably
also Mar-A-Lago down in Florida
um the documents allegedly made their
way look at this to the storage unit as
part of a three thousand pound transport
of miscellaneous items shipped from
Virginia to Florida they're just in a
storage unit they're like in a pod it
was full of suits and swords and
wrestling belts and all sorts of things
A source told the Washington Post who
asserted Trump had likely never even
been to the unit sources told the post
that the material was turned over to the
FBI which declined to supervise the
searches those familiar with the
investigation also indicated to the post
that classified materials were not
recovered from searches at Bedminster
and Trump Tower only from the storage
unit Trump has been obsessed with
people's handling of classified
information for years and years and
years and it turns out that he is the
worst remember all of this stuff okay
we're going to move on and yet
she didn't know the word the letter c on
a document
right she didn't even know what that
word what that letter meant you know
it's amazing I'm watching Hillary go
over facts
and she's going after fact after fact
and she's lying again because she said
she you know what she did with emails
was fine you think it was fine to delete
33 000 emails I don't think so she said
the 33 000 emails had to do with her
daughter's wedding number one and a yoga
class well maybe we'll give three or
three or four or five or something 33
000 emails deleted and now she's saying
there wasn't anything wrong and more
importantly that was after getting a
subpoena that wasn't before that was
after she got it from the United States
Congress and I'll be honest I am so
disappointed in Congressman yeah so
Hillary very very untrustworthy how
about George H.W bush yep nope that's uh
that's also very very bad he can't be
trusted either George H.W bush took
millions of documents to a former
bowling alley and a former Chinese
restaurant where they combined them so
they're in a bowling alley slash Chinese
restaurant okay now that story of course
wasn't true as you might imagine what
actually happened was that uh the
national uh archives
rented a facility which previously was a
laundry and Chinese restaurant the
documents were under the right
possession and supervised at Elk points
it just is not even remotely analogous
but he was bad okay remember Trump's
promise about documents in 2016. on
political corruption
we are going to restore honor to our
government right in my Administration
I'm going to enforce all laws concerning
Lord the protection of classified
information
[Applause]
no one will be above the law no one
other than I guess Trump himself it sort
of seems uh also Trump saying he is
better than Obama Bush and Clinton when
it comes to documents they've been given
all the time these are other presidents
all the time needed because you're
supposed to have as much time as you
need
and complete deference when it came to
their documents and their papers take as
much as you need Barack Hussein Obama
moved more than 20 truckloads over 33
million pages of documents both
classified and unclassified to a poorly
built and totally unsafe former
furniture store located in a rather bad
neighborhood in Chicago
with no security by the way
George W bush stored 68 million pages in
a warehouse in Texas and lost 22 million
White House emails he lost 22 million
emails can you imagine if I lost two
emails that say this is terrible
it must have been nuclear in those two
[Applause]
correct so you get it Trump's the best
at everything all the time it will be
interesting if we ever do find out
exactly everything Trump stole on his
way out are there still missing
documents even after this particular
find and we have a situation apparently
here in the United States where top
secret documents intelligence
it seems quite poorly managed to the
point where this can even happen like
there's there's two sides of course to
all of this Trump Insanity on the one
hand no one has really tested our
systems the way that Donald Trump has
tested them
and so him doing this stuff is wacky but
also some of the systems haven't worked
particularly well it's odd that agencies
didn't necessarily know about every
single one of these documents as soon as
they were missing oh some turned up in a
storage unit all right I can't wait for
the defense of this because it always
boils down to incompetence and as it was
someone else pointing fingers and also
this isn't really a bad thing and also
Obama did it worse and blah blah blah
blah blah Obama yeah that guy you
remember him
um I don't know what the next step is on
the classified documents but like we
said after the Mar-A-Lago stuff happened
that was not going to be the the last we
heard about documents and indeed more
have already turned up our sponsor real
paper makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
never from trees meaning no
deforestation sustainability and climate
change can be a tricky topic for people
of all ages it can be particularly
challenging to talk about with kids and
real paper recently launched the little
lemurs box a 24 pack of their bamboo
toilet paper with a beautifully
Illustrated Kids book that tells an
exciting story of sustainability the box
is designed to spark creativity and kids
create an opportunity to talk about
deforestation plastic pollution in a way
that's light and easy and with the
holidays here the book makes a great
gift for a little one on your list real
papers little lemurs box and all of the
other products are available in Easy
hassle-free subscriptions or just simple
one-time purchases on their website all
orders are conveniently delivered to
your door with free shipping and this is
the best part 100 recyclable plastic
free packaging go to realpaper.com
lemur and sign up for a subscription
using Code Pacman at checkout to get 30
off your first order and free shipping
the link is down below